there was something to be discovered
about the
737 max and if you had been a bit more
suspicious and tested it better we would
have found it
and it's the same thing with most harm
that's been done
by automation so far i would say so i
don't know if you did you
hear of a company called night capital
no
so good that means you didn't invest in
them earlier
they deployed this automated rating
system yes
all nice and shiny they didn't
understand it as well as they thought
and it went about losing 10 million
bucks per minute
yeah for 44 minutes straight no until
someone presumably was like oh no
shut this up you know uh was it evil no
it was again misplaced trust something
they didn't fully understand right and
um there have been so many um even when
people have been killed by
robots it's quite rare still but in act
factory accidents it's in every single
case been not
malice just that the robot didn't
understand that a human is different
from an order part or whatever and and
we um so this is where i think there's
so so much
opportunity for physics approach where
you just
aim for a higher level of understanding
and if you look at the
all these systems that we talked about
from the from
reinforcement learning systems and
dancing robots
to all these neural networks that power
gpt 3
and and go playing software stuff
they're all basically black boxes
much like not so different from if you
teach a human something you have no idea
how their brain works
right except the human brain at least
has been
error corrected during many many
centuries of evolution in a way that
these
some of these systems have not right and
my my mit research is entirely focused
on demystifying this black box
intelligible intelligence is my slogan
that's a good line intelligible
intelligence yeah it's not that we
shouldn't settle for something that
seems intelligent but we should it
should be intelligible so that we
actually trust it because we understand
it right like again elon trusts his
rockets because he understands newton's
laws and
thrust and how everything works
you